per quanto difficile da credere forse
per alcuni di voi addirittura
impensabile tutto questo prima o poi
avrà un senso ciao ragazzi benvenuti a
un nuovo video sul mio canale ora un po
di mesi fa insieme i miei cugini abbiamo
regalato a mia nonna un fotolibro
fotolibro che ha commosso me lei voi
chiunque toccava questo fotolibro
praticamente piange per versava liquidi
dagli occhi questo regalo è stato
possibile grazie al ceo e che ci ha
chiesto di collaborare nuovamente ora
per chi non li conoscesse sappiate che
c'è un grazie tipo la sua app suo sito
dà la possibilità non so di poter
stampare vedete in maniera facile
ricordi sotto forma di un fotolibro post
puzzle cover per telefono tasse
calendari insomma chi più ne ha più ne
metta
durante il periodo prenatalizio oltre
alle varie cose che potete fare ceo e dà
la possibilità di creare anche dei
calendari dell'avvento personalizzate
documento che io tipo non so mai che
cosa regalare la mia famiglia durante il
natale ho pensato di cavalcare questa
collaborazione per risolvere l'annoso
problema dei doni natalizi tra i
calendari ho selezionato quello che si
poteva magnate nella dimensione più
grande perché tanto appetito e
soprattutto avevo già in mente che cosa
voglio starci sopra e prego che ogni
particolare ogni dettaglio si vedesse
molto bene una cosa che ho sempre fatto
ogni natale con la mia famiglia è che me
la ricordo tantissimo è il presepe così
ho pensato di utilizzare come soggetto
un presepe fatto con la mia famiglia nel
senso proprio con la mia famiglia
ma per farlo ho dovuto prima assegnare
velocemente i personaggi allora perché
diamo lui e toast cosa ho fatto uno
sketch di come immaginavo la foto finale
e subito mi sono reso conto che avrei
avuto bisogno di costruire a parte lo
sfondo per poi aggiungere in un secondo
momento i personaggi travestiti in
postproduzione personaggio che
ovviamente avrei dovuto scattare da soli
all'interno di un limbo bianco prima
cosa che ho fatto creare il set
quindi utilizzare per la base delle
palle di giornale che ho sfilato e
scocciato insieme per creare la
struttura che ho poi foderata con carta
roccia o sparso di muschio ghiaia è un
po di farina per fare da neve anche
mandarla in caciara per quanto riguarda
invece personaggi beh li stiamo
aspettando
siamo pronti con c'è migliore
no no
oltre
perché questo per chiedere poi capire se
si guarda un po come le cose mi
raccomando più venduto la nostra mente
di quell'amico nell'altro
se ne stavano le mani
ok centurioni john spada con le
infradito e arrivato il momento della
pasticcera fin di male se vendola così
diretta da lavoro ecco pronta per
preparare i minion già mature dal
franamento bricchi a questa è la
dimensione di una sua torta è riuscito a
portare se stessa
[Musica]
esatto
sia una grande professionista
e allora
nulla da ridire 30 comma gioco tu stai
suonando le domeniche agosto
quando gesù
[Musica]
il corpo è sempre un momento bello così
e gira diverso
quest'anno
bravo molto molto bravi ma scappato da
un centro sociale stava di avvicinarsi
muschio amarezza e la parte dove non ha
interpretato
poi quelli di robben nonna dei perfetto
entry hashing francese
raiola
si è bellissimo cambi grande interprete
è bastato semplicemente dirle ti ricordi
qualcuno fabbro
martello
comunque viva
si vuol chiudere uno spavento produzione
vero
[Musica]
il martello e di nuovo segno guardinghi
vertici
da pescatore e dei tatuati nell'anno
zero martella mercato
esposto giocatori mette vicino a como
gli un secondino notare l'ultimo giorno
utile per questo tra tutti sei il
fratello giuseppe e sempre in questo
devo essere un padre amorevole
[Applauso]
più
un altro
commento
[Applauso]
carini pinocchio la foto sul suo futuro
ma dai fantasmini mentre il santo catore
visto due nazioni o che qui per cento
non è il più bravo è pazzesco veramente
vinciamo la faccia basta invece di
quest'album non ci siano gli sta
cercando una fase 2 2 da enrico ecco che
teneva le difese ricchi del bue prendete
ragazzi se raggiungiamo 60.000 light
carlo ti chiamano tra queens i ragazzi
ma altro che due americani poi è
spaventosamente poi nome a poverino si
il bue l'asinello la vittima perché la
cosa c'e da lì
[Musica]
senza trucco shadow me era giusto e
arrivo come credibilità e appena apre
bocca diventa l'asino è pazzesco ora
questa mia madre
ce l'avete tutte quel sapore
dell'oriente nome da spiega nome
[Musica]
meridione meriti ore 9 ball da silva oro
incenso e mirra giustino veramente
importante questi costumi e avrete così
assetto mentre quanti quasi in poi non
essere forse sfumate le se viste le
ciabatte il giovane ancora senza
sorridere
una volta saltatore ora mentre dal fatto
che gesù abbia la testa di guglielmi
ragazzi i re magi un livello altissimo
vale la pena solo per loro sono dolori
ma quale fiere incredibile l'ultimo
verona la liga
come si fa a esatto c'è gesù con la
testa di puglia
[Musica]
non sapevo che conta
questo testimonia dovranno nascita del
messia pazzesco si smette mai di
imparare e mezzo giapponese per un altro
[Musica]
urgenza di vedere gesù urgenza
bravissimo prova a fare l'espressione un
po più da pecora ok ora sta giocando
l'erba stai guardando sono passati un po
di giorni da quando abbiamo finito lo
shooting non lo potete vedere ma qui c'è
una meraviglia è ritornato le giunse
vuoi e mi è arrivata la foto avevo
un'idea che devono stato all'inizio ma
ho contattato christian buonomo che un
ragazzo speciale io conosco e che è tipo
uno dei maghi forse il mago in italia
della post produzione che mi ha detto
guarda tranquillo manda tutto a me ci
penso io è spam
lo state vedendo adesso schermo intero
con do ti prego non fare questi versi io
non so se vi rendete conto di lavoro che
ha fatto
vi prego guardate la grotta guardatemi
enrico errico asino no va bene
no vabbè ragazzi culto e poi qui abbiamo
tutti quanti che sono stati inseriti in
maniera pazzesca a ricatti in maniera
pazzesca all'interno 9 st il più piccolo
quasi per niente sono stati inseriti
tutti quanti nova dai ragazzi che per i
ragazzi che brienne un'opera d'arte o no
no no ma lui è assurdo ha fatto un
lavoro eccellente calcolate mi piace
così tanto che adesso farò l'ordine con
questo ma vi lasciamo un link qua sotto
in modo potevi scaricare la foto qualora
vogliate ordinare anche voi lo stesso
calendario che abbiamo creato farlo è
super facile basta andare sul sito di
ceo e si carica con l'albero di natale
che cosa carina scorrere tra i prodotti
finché non si arriva ai calendari
calendari dell'avvento questo della
kinder
io ho preso il 48 36 che il più grande e
andarci a caricare la foto c'è stato
indirizzo di casa quindi lei mi dovrei
far vivere proprio tutti i passaggi in
dio a ragazzi naturalmente potete farvi
il calendario che volete voi non dovete
per forza scaricare la foto che abbiamo
fatto noi e quindi all'interno del sito
potete caricare quello che ti pare
adesso l'unica cosa che mi rimane da
fare è aspettare che arrivi il
calendario ci mettono più o meno
quindici giorni quindi se volete
prenderlo in tempo per l'uno sbrigatevi
niente vi lascio alle reazioni e ci
vediamo nel futuro
che cos'è che la foto che abbiamo fatto
quello che avete più quella botta visi
ma un male a farmi vedere tutti questo
pur bordo si no che meraviglia pachino
ha fatto questo è questo qui è lo
sponsor del vostro video e poi questo
qui è un calendario dell'avvento quindi
se tu lo sai ci sono dei numeri tu il
primo dicembre dove l'uno aiuta mente al
colon o con un 4
ogni giorno devi aprire una casella e
c'è dentro un dolcino no ma chi ha avuto
il mio nostra insieme a chi è lo sponsor
del nostro video o signore o no
capolavoro ma siamo su un calendario
davvero non verrà venduto
sì sì chi vuole solo potrà far stampare
con quell'immagine ac vostra credeva beh
nessuno
francesco un po penalizzato c'è tanto
che è meglio chi chiusi
ciao